there's a reason grep is installed on  every Linux distro and was copied on  Windows Powershell with feinster which  is honestly a much better name because  grep is all about finding strings across  multiple files let's imagine you're  being spied on by the CIA and you need  to quickly delete all those files  referencing the Apollo Moon missions  grep can help you by taking a string or  regex pattern followed by a file name  then return all the lines that contain  that text use the end flag to also print  the line number or use V to invert it  and show all the lines without that text  use R to search an entire directory and  it also acts as a filter when piped into  other commands like LS  but if the fed's already busted down  your door and shot your dog it's too  late you should have watched a video  about said or awk which are similar  tools that also support find and replace